donde lo dejamos en el último vídeo nos
fuimos encontrando la superficie de un
toro la forma de una dona verdad y
hacíamos esto al tomar un integral de
superficie y teníamos que encontrar la
derivada parcial de nuestra
parametrización respecto de ese y
también respecto de t ahora ya estamos
listos para tomar el producto cruz de
estos dos y a continuación resolveremos
la integral doble y averiguaremos cuál
es la superficie del toro así que vamos
a hacerlo paso a paso podríamos tomar
aquí primero el producto cruz que es una
operación bastante peluda es muy
complicada y por eso es que no ve uno
muchos ejemplos resueltos de este tipo
de cosas pero bueno vamos a tomar el
producto cruz de estos dos compadres en
la parcial de r respecto de ese cruz la
parcial de r respecto de t muy bien es
un producto cruz o producto vectorial
esto recordemos que es el determinante y
vamos a escribir los vectores unidad en
el primer renglón verdad
j y acá los pongo así de separados
porque puede puede ocupar mucho espacio
después vamos a poner en el siguiente
renglón en el siguiente renglón va la
entrada o más bien las componentes de
parcial de respecto de s así que déjenme
copiar este que es la primera entrada de
la parcial de r respecto a ese y lo
colocamos este chico por aquí ahora
copiamos este otro y pegamos en esta
segunda columna y ahora copiamos este
compadre
esto nos está ahorrando mucho tiempo
verdad y lo pegamos aquí entonces en
esta fila en este renglón ya colocamos
los componentes de la parcial de rd
respecto de ese y ahora estoy copiando y
pegando los de la parcial de rd respecto
de t entonces copiamos y pegamos y
esto por último bueno no tenemos que
copiar y pegar pero bueno ya lo hicimos
con los otros vamos a hacerlo con este
así que también para este cero ahora el
producto cruz de esto es literalmente el
determinante de esta matriz verdad
abusando un poco de la notación ya lo
sabemos ahora bien vamos a vamos a ver
qué es esto entonces primero tomamos el
el vector y multiplicamos por el sub
determinante que nos queda de quitar el
renglón y la columna verdad así que
pondremos que esto es igual a y por la
el determinante de la sub matriz que
resulta de quitar su columna y su
renglón que es menos sacos en nuestro
seno de s por 0 menos menos b más a
cociendo sct por ako seno de esa verdad
así que simplemente nos queda
multiplicar
los términos menos de masako seno de ese
seno dt y acosen ode es de verdad
perfecto entonces copiamos a coseno de s
vamos a poner recuerden que lleva un
signo menos verdad y con el signo menos
que teníamos originalmente se hace más
así que simplemente ponemos de más a
coseno de s por el seno de t por el seno
de t
así que tenemos el término para el
vector y ahora va a ser menos j verdad
porque vamos intercambiando el signo
según la columna que nos vayamos tomando
así que esto será menos j
- j y tachamos su columna y su d y su
renglón y nos queda el determinante de
la sub matriz que es menos hacen o dt
seno de ese por cero menos de masako
seno de ese coseno dt por ako seno de s
pero con el menos que ya teníamos
originalmente entonces realmente se hace
signo más verdad en realidad quienes
tenemos que multiplicar al final son a
coseno ds por demás a coseno de seco
seno de t correcto déjenme ponerlo con
todos sus signos menos que le
corresponde así que es menos ve más a
kossen lo desee con seno de t por
por por nos falta a coseno de s ya
después haremos la limpieza de esto
verdad digo porque podríamos de una vez
poner los signos más es es simplemente
el algoritmo verdad ahora por último
vamos a ver a quién le corresponde el
término para acá así que ponemos más acá
por el determinante de la sub matriz que
resulta de quitar la columna de acá y el
renglón de acá así que sería menos hacen
los dts no de ese por menos ve más a
coseno de ese seno de t verdad y ahora
menos bueno en realidad es éste moradito
que es hacerlo de tse no de s
y lo multiplicamos por este otro
moradito que es b más a coseno de ese
seno de t y fíjense que ya quiten los
menos porque menos por menos da más
verdad así que ya no es necesario
ponerlo y ahora ahora
lo que tenemos que hacer es sumar el
inverso aditivo de los números que nos
restan verdad en este caso si tomamos el
inverso aditivo con el menos que por ahí
encontramos en la entrada
que estamos poniendo con morado a coseno
dts no sé si bien tiene un menos así que
con el menos que le corresponde del
determinante se hace más y luego
multiplicamos por ver más a coseno ds
con seno de t
muy bien ya ves ahora porque no
encontramos muchos ejemplos resueltos es
un poco complicado así que vamos a hacer
un poco de limpieza
vamos a ver cómo simplificar esto así
que primero vamos a multiplicar déjenme
encontrar el paso más fácil sólo sería
sacar un factor b más a coseno de s del
término cada verdad de hecho de todos
los términos tenemos ese factor en todos
los términos así que sólo vamos a
factorizar lo y dejarlo fuera así que
toda esta cosa loca se puede escribir
como b más a coseno de s ya que los
factores amos y esto multiplicará
va a multiplicar
vamos a poner las componentes que sería
a coseno de s déjenme escribirlo en
verde primero así que este verde y este
es lo que resulta de factorizar de
masako seno de ese así que sería algo
seno de ese seno de t y ahora
multiplicamos por nuestro vector y
verdad es lo único que nos falta vamos a
dejar dejar los vectores en color rojo
ahora para la componente en jotas y
factor izamos el b masako seno de s lo
único que nos resta es poner a coseno de
s coseno de t simplemente ahí cambiando
el orden de estos productos que subraya
en verde y finalmente multiplicamos por
el vector unidad j muy bien ya que
dejamos el b más a coseno desde fuera
ahora vamos a ver qué pasa con acá
estamos realmente tachando el b masako
seno de ese de sus de su componente
correcto así que lo que nos resta
es poner en verde y multiplicar seno de
t por acs no de s que es esta primera
parte que subrayamos y luego sumarle que
bueno de una vez si simplificamos es
hace no seno de ese x seno cuadrado de t
verdad estamos multiplicando dos veces
seno de t así es que eso nos queda y
ahora sumamos a coseno de ts no desee
por coseno dt que si nos damos cuenta
multiplicamos dos veces coseno de t por
lo tanto nos queda a seno de ese coseno
cuadrado de t y todo esto todo esto
último por el vector unidad k
muy bien así que las cosas ya se ven un
poquito más simplificadas pero algo
podría saltar a la vista verdad tenemos
seno cuadrado y coseno cuadrado en la
componente de acá que multiplica seno de
ese y claro esa es la identidad
trigonométricas más fácil que conocemos
así que ese primer término lo podemos
simplificar al al factorizar a seno de
ese verdad así que esto realmente lo
podemos poner como acs por seno cuadrado
de t más coseno cuadrado de t
muy bien y bueno multiplicando a nuestro
vector unitario acá pero ya sabemos que
se lo cuadrado más coseno cuadrado de
cualquier cosa es en realidad uno esto
es igual a 1 por lo que este último
término se simplifica a seno de s porque
muy bien ahora ya hemos llegado bastante
lejos ya ya averiguamos cuál es el
producto cruz de estos dos dos vectores
que son las derivadas parciales de
nuestra parametrización y hemos podido
averiguar que que está este este
producto cruz tiene esta expresión ahora
lo que nos falta es realmente escribir
la norma de este vector verdad así que
si reescribimos nada más este producto
cruz nos queda además a coseno de ese x
a ccoo seno de ese seno de t por el
vector y vamos a seguirlo dejando en
rojito más a coseno de ese coseno de t y
todo esto por el vector j
y finalmente nos queda más a seno de ese
seno de ese por el vector k
en el siguiente vídeo lo que vamos a
tratar de hacer es calcular la norma de
esto que va a ser relativamente fácil
muy bien entonces esta expresión es lo
que tenemos enmarcado acá arriba y bueno
ya vamos más de diez minutos tomaremos
la magnitud de este vector y ya después
si tenemos tiempo tomaremos la doble
integral para calcular la superficie del
toro